what are we making today okay so today
we are making strawberry lemon
hand pies and what i love about these is
it is like this nostalgic thing there's
something about these pies that remind
me of my childhood i can't wait for you
to bite into them did you read this
recipe did you make this recipe did you
have it in childhood did you find it
somewhere where is the origin so we have
a little sweet truck at the silos that
we call maggie for short for magnolia
and that's our sweet truck and it's kind
of this nostalgic food truck that's got
all these hand pies people could do this
with their kids they could do this in
the kitchen like it's
very simple teach me and i'm all about
desserts and food that you can just get
the basics and then modify it however
you like so we're doing strawberry and
lemon but the sky's the limit on how you
fill these things so you could do
blueberry and gruyere anything you want
yes so today we're going to be doing
strawberry lemon the first thing we're
going to make is the filling okay let's
do this so it's the strawberries
depending on if strawberries are in
season you can it's just two cups of
whole strawberries or two cups of frozen
strawberries
just turn that up just a little bit okay
so we're going to these are frozen
strawberries i thought them just a
little bit but you just want to dump
that what's the best way
oh yeah baby well that was on and a
little warm what's the best way that he
saw a frozen straw just let him i just
let them sit out for a second okay these
are absolutely the smell that smells so
good from here is so
good
so just stir that around we're gonna add
a third
cup of the sugar
okay add in this cornstarch it's two
tablespoons that's gonna be
the thing that thickens this so there's
a roux
yes component and then as this gets warm
we just wanna break down the
strawberries because again this is the
filling so it's going to be more like a
jam or a jelly
so now that it's kind of bubbling up we
can cut the heat
and
now look
it's magically chilled and finished but
this is our filling
this is the beauty though this is the
beauty there we go
this is our little egg wash
all right i see you're ready marks too
which yeah this is fun so we're so the
dough's already been made but what i
love about
this dough is it's kind of your typical
pie crust but it's i've added eggs and a
little milk to make it a little more
flaky so you can see
i like flaky here i want like a crescent
roll yes so that egg is what makes it a
little flakier so now the dough is one
of those things that would have taken an
hour to chill so we just went ahead and
did that it's done magic of tv we're
going to fill these little pies with
about a tablespoon of the filling hold
on we're gonna let's brush those edges
so they don't um
yeah and just do one one side so that's
gonna be what seams them together so
let's just brush
the edges touch the edges
like sealing an envelope yep and you're
just going to do it on this top
layer
and then we're going to fill
on the inside of that little border
and a tablespoon what's a style you want
to bring back what's a style you want to
go away
that's a good question
let me fill my berries
um a style that i want to bring back
i think
like as i you know i look at i have a
bunch of old design books i don't even
know i just love to open them up and see
and i think what i love is
that curiosity that in some ways that
quirkiness that randomness i feel like
homes have just gotten so at least what
we see they're very cooking cutters it's
very it's almost predictable now and i
think it's like let's bring back that
like unpredictability you know and i
think it's a balance of you know for us
i work with clients and so at the end of
the day i give the client what they want
but the the fun is in the especially the
projects we get to do ourselves that
it's just more like hey we're going to
sell this later so i can kind of just be
as wild as i want watch what i'm doing
here just pushing down and you just pull
out like that you want to just make sure
drew that that filling doesn't ooze out
so by sealing this with that egg wash
pat pat okay so look we're going to just
give this a cutie little border oh i'm
oozing it's okay
go like this really quick boop just do
like four and that just allows
the filling to breathe when you have it
okay what's your happily ever after oh
oh i think we always say this we're like
that we're sitting on that same porch in
those rocking chairs
watching the sun go down and say we did
it well
all our kids
off and gone in a really healthy good
way but saying we did it well
that's it it's very simple
but we're still holding hands and we
still really like each other please god
see i'm so aggressively single but when
i'm around you and chip it makes me go i
gotta and maybe i should
spreadage my wings your wing he still
says i love you all the time kisses and
i love you
can you teach me
i i'm like you need to just
write a book on how to treat a woman i
mean he's just a real sexy picture yeah
use
he would love that um he's just a doll
he's sweet
[Music]
you